[Music]
so what do you want to sing tonight
about this just data we didn't invite
you guys to sing we invited you to watch
I'll kiss Cuse me I just thought you
guys were so busy with your awesome jobs
and amazing lives I am actually we're so
bright and shiny still pretty they look
like they was all breast fits on this
performance to support the troops in
Europe one last show together who is
with me
oh yeah welcome to Spain fellas so this
is the first base will we be going to
second base with you guys that's a no
for me so on the tour we've got three
bands you guys are seeing other people's
songs right like a cover band they're
trying to intimidate us let's just do it
to a reef off running man throw
we like to keep it oral
we're that everybody is that are at the
one thing that we do then then we are at
that thing
alright ladies pick up your tits we're
going to show them that we are not a
joke my record label wants to sign one
of the bands but we don't want the bends
we want you what I did not see this
coming
family we support each other we like
sisters Aubrey he is Aubry isn't it I
can't I'm part of the group Becca it's a
big opportunity for you
[Applause]
[Music]
bye-bye Bela's it really does feel like
a bhaijaan thangka what are you doing
don't ya
if you cry don't cry don't make that
face I'm not doing it
[Music]